gamespot news hi Mary here with a  gamespot news update well Microsoft has  said it will eventually release official  drivers that will enable the xbox one  controller to work on PC a modder has  released a workarounds which will let  you play today the Mater Lucas Aziz said  in a youtube video that it took them  about a day's work to engineer the  workaround there's a few steps involved  to get it working but any confident  Windows user should be able to get it up  and running in about 10 minutes Lucas  provided a walkthrough video on his  YouTube which we have a link to on  gamespot com in short the workaround  requires you to install a set of drivers  and software to fool your PC into  assuming a regular xbox 360 controller  has been connected to the machine  however this is not an official mod so  proceed with the installation at your  own risk to keep up with all the xbox  one and controller modification news  check out GameSpot's calm